[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
[Aplausos]
u Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
alrededor del 56% de la población
mundial vive en ciudades esto es 4.400
millones de habitantes una población
urbana que se duplicará en el 2050 según
datos del Banco Mundial esto implica
muchos retos en temas de movilidad y
sostenibilidad es posible que una gran
urbe garantice una buena calidad de vida
de qué forma se puede mitigar el impacto
que tiene en el medio ambiente las
infraestructuras urbanas de todo esto
vamos a hablar con la economista peruana
de medio ambiente Carmen santuarias
Muchísimas gracias Carmen por estar con
nosotros Gracias Aida por la invitación
Bueno Carmen santuarias usted es
profesora asociada en economía en spi
que es la escuela superior de
profesiones inmobiliarias de París
además es miembro del Consejo científico
del programa de investigación y tecop
del ministerio francés de la transición
ecológica y estudia el impacto
medioambiental de las urbes la
restauración de ecosistemas urbanos y el
valor que los ciudadanos le dan a la
naturaleza Cuando tenemos una ciudad
Carmen por ejemplo de 10 millones de
habitantes se necesitan mucho transporte
público urbano suministro de agua de
Electricidad hay mucho cemento pocos
espacios verdes esto crea lo que llaman
las islas de calor que afectan al medio
ambiente y a la biodiversidad de la zona
En definitiva a la calidad de vida no de
los de los urbanitas de hecho en las
ciudades siempre tenemos algunos grados
más no que que en las zonas cercanas de
campo
Qué son estas islas de calor
las islas de calor han sido estudiadas
principalmente en zonas urbanas nos
damos cuenta que son el asfalto el
cemento
estas zonas muy minerales que no nos
permiten poder reflejar el calor que
recibimos durante durante el día
entonces podemos encontrar que existe
una variación de uno a dos grados
Celsius entre las zonas urbanas y las
zonas Rurales Entonces esta esta
acumulación que podemos sentir que se es
más presente dentro de la ciudad es lo
que le llamamos las islas de calor y Qué
consecuencias tiene para el medio
ambiente esas islas de calor y para la
calidad de vida de la gente que vive en
las urbes no es solamente una sensación
de calor mayor hemos visto que
efectivamente las olas de calor que
hemos podido vivir en Europa han tenido
daños mayores
ha habido muertes hemos tenido también
efectivamente no podemos trabajar cuando
hará 50 grados en París vamos vamos a
poder ver una baja de productividad
importante ligada a estos impactos del
cambio climático dentro de nuestras
ciudades
me acuerdo Ahora cuando me está
comentando esto que en alguna ocasión he
visto incluso imágenes de cómo se freía
un huevo en el capó de un coche no en
creo que era en Madrid eso cómo la
sensación que tenemos a veces de andar
en pleno verano Y como que el asfalto se
te pega a las suelas de los zapatos para
contrarrestar todo esto estas
consecuencias que pueden ser dramáticas
no como muertes o incluso que no podamos
ni ir a trabajar los economistas
Proponen restaurar lo que se llama
servicios ecosistémicos urbanos
cuéntenos Qué son bueno esta este
concepto de servicios ecosistémicos nace
con todo el movimiento de estudiar el
capital natural y dar a conocer el valor
que el funcionamiento de los ecosistemas
tiene sobre nuestra economía y podemos
mencionar que un servicio son todos los
beneficios que la naturaleza nos da y de
los que nosotros aprovechamos Entonces
por ejemplo la naturaleza nos da sombra
Entonces esto nos permite luchar contra
los hilos de calor el hecho de estar en
proximidades de fuentes de agua también
nos permite tener un clima más temperado
estos lugares vegetales nos permiten
también tener un aire más puro entonces
podemos también a mejorar la calidad del
agua del aire y luchar contra las
emisiones de algunos contaminantes
atmosféricos entonces son algunos
ejemplos de servicios ecosistémicos
entonces hay que combinar eso con las
infraestructuras que se construyen no en
en las ciudades por ejemplo en el caso
del transporte
desnaturaliza mucho el suelo con vías
férreas con puentes con túneles
autopistas De qué manera se pueden
aprovechar estas infraestructuras para
ir no sé pues reforestando plantando
árboles o poniendo fuentes de agua
acabas de describir efectivamente uno de
los principales puntos de alguno de los
temas de investigación que tenemos que
es integrar la vegetalización o la
renaturación
renaturalización de la ciudad dentro de
las infraestructuras cómo las
infraestructuras que al mismo tiempo
proveen un servicio público pueden
también ser fuente de restauración de
servicios ecosistémicos Entonces es
decirnos cómo estas infraestructuras Que
fragmentan nuestro paisaje fragmentan el
ecosistema pueden también ser una
oportunidad para restaurar la ciudad y
restaurar los ecosistemas urbanos O sea
que cada proyecto por ejemplo cada metro
de autopista tiene que haber un árbol
plantado cada metro de tranvía tiene que
haber tantas tantos metros cuadrados de
verde actualmente tiene un proyecto en
Lyon en el este de Francia que se llama
sema en francés que se podría Traducir
como Sembrador
explíquenos En qué consiste yo creo que
va por ahí no el asunto
Gracias por presentar este proyecto que
se basa principalmente en la
vegetalización del tranvía en las zonas
periféricas de León y lo que buscamos es
dar a conocer el valor de estos
servicios ecosistémicos y por el valor
cambiar también el uso de estos suelos
que generalmente son utilizados como
bordes de infraestructuras para que
acojan una vegetación entonces sabemos
que la vegetación del tranvía no nos va
a salvar de estos Hilos de calor pero
van a motivar a que las infraestructuras
a proximidad los edificios los comercios
las viviendas también inciten a integrar
los espacios verdes y a buscar una
conectividad ecológica por la
infraestructura de estas diferentes
espacios verdes entonces podemos
imaginar que la infraestructura nos
permite vegetalizar una parte de la
ciudad para continuar a vegetalizarla en
todos los ambientes que podamos y te da
también un aspecto socioeconómico no esa
conexión digamos una periferia más
desfavorecida menos conectada con el
centro de Lyon bueno en este proyecto
que podemos traducirlo como Sembrador
nos interesamos a la extinción del
tranvía en la el municipio de sanfu
Sansón es una ciudad al sureste francés
que tiene diferentes dificultades no
solamente en una baja cobertura de
árboles
a la escala de la metrópolis de León
estamos hablando de una cobertura de
alrededor de 27% de superficies en
espacios verdes en santfong esto es
estimado a 15% entonces hay una
ilegalidad en la repartición de Estos
espacios verdes pero al mismo tiempo
tenemos un espacio bastante
desfavorizado en temas de desempleo 40%
de jóvenes se encuentran en Búsqueda de
empleo vemos que esta situación
socioambiental
podría acoger y ayudar a abrir esta
hacia el barrio siete de León y
facilitar no solamente el servicio
público sino también reducir estas
ilegalidades socioambientales se puede
establecer alguna conexión entre Lyon y
otras ciudades por ejemplo en
Latinoamérica
Gracias por la pregunta porque
Efectivamente es un poco lo que buscamos
en alguno de nuestros trabajos nos
preguntamos Cómo nuestras ciudades
nuestras urbes latinoamericanas que
necesitan nuevas infraestructuras de
transporte está previsto en los años a
venir numerosas ciudades están
invirtiendo en mejorar su servicio de
transporte público podrían integrar
también una estrategia de vegetalización
de estos ponerse el caso aún O sí
Esperamos que sea el caso hay numerosas
extensiones de buses que se están
realizando que se están proyectando en
los años a venir entonces mirar cómo
integrar las espacios verdes la
naturaleza de la restauración de
servicios ecosistémicos y de nuestro
suelo por las infraestructuras de
transporte
y en esa vía se inscribe digamos
el central que es otro proyecto en Perú
y en Costa Rica que es justamente para
capacitar a profesionales y también
funcionarios en ese ámbito
efectivamente hemos sido lorea debemos
recibido este año un programa de
cooperación entre Francia y América
Latina Este programa es que se llama
central nos permite construir un módulo
de formación de capacitación dirigido no
solamente a nuestros estudiantes sino
también a funcionarios de los
ministerios de transporte para conversar
para presentar un poco los trabajos
sobre los impactos de las
infraestructuras sobre los instrumentos
económicos que podrían acompañar esta
vegetalización pero también trabajar
sobre la evaluación Ambiental de las
infraestructuras en Latinoamérica
entonces Central es un proyecto de
capacitación de formación y al mismo
tiempo un proyecto de creación de redes
de investigación están realizando un
estudios sobre
cómo percibe la gente no
estos cambios estas iniciativas
el diagnóstico de los actores me
comentaba los resultados aún no se han
publicado pero qué nos puede adelantar
porque hay mucha gente que se queja y se
han puesto macetas en la acera Y ahora
van los perros a hacer sus necesidades
ahora esta calle por la que podíamos
circular ya no se puede circular y tengo
que hacer No sé cuántos kilómetros para
llegar al parque o sea hay un cambio de
paradigma digamos pero no sé si la gente
está receptiva ya sé que el estudio Aún
está se está haciendo y los resultados
no están publicados pero que nos pueda
adelantar Bueno les puedo mencionar un
poco sobre la metodología que utilizamos
lo que buscamos es analizar los valores
que les damos a diferentes servicios y
para el análisis de estos valores
tratamos a dar a conocer también este
capital este capital natural que cuando
no lo contabilizamos que cuando no le
damos algunas unidades monetarias detrás
finalmente no lo integramos en nuestras
decisiones Entonces
al poner algunas números en estos en
estos servicios que la naturaleza nos da
lo que buscamos es integrarlos en
nuestra decisión entonces probablemente
no estamos integrando totalmente el
valor de estos diferentes servicios y
por eso es que nuestras decisiones no no
están realmente en el sentido de el
bienestar propio es como poner en la
balanza no A ver vamos a perder una
calle de circulación de coches pero se
gana A lo mejor en respirar mejor no
exponer monetizar digamos poner la
balanza No qué fuerza en temas de
infraestructura realmente necesitamos
esas infraestructuras para un desarrollo
económico para el comercio para el
traslado y al mismo tiempo estas
infraestructuras es una oportunidad es
una oportunidad para restaurar para
crear continuidad ecológica y como lo
mencionaba para promover la
digitalización en otras espacios ya nos
queda muy poco tiempo en pocas palabras
para usted Cuál es la ciudad ideal en
temas de infraestructuras y
biodiversidad Bueno eso es una pregunta
que pienso que nos interesa a todos como
ciudadanos hace poco Tuvimos una una
jornada de trabajo dentro de la escuela
que se interesó al inmobiliario
sostenible y a la ciudad del mañana en
esta en esta jornada de trabajo
imaginamos una ciudad no solamente verde
pero sino una ciudad que es apropiada
por la gente yo imagino una ciudad con
Terrazas en las que tenemos diferentes
actividades actividades de agricultura
urbana imagino que estas Terrazas son
parte de nuestros de nuestros edificios
imagino que en estos lugares nos
encontramos la covid nos ha nos Busca a
encontrarnos en estos lugares donde no
teníamos uso antes entonces
verdes además de solamente darnos
servicios ecosistémicos también nos dan
un capital que podemos llamar un capital
ambiental que es un capital social que
nace de nuestro interés en la
restauración de la ciudad bueno por
deseo que podamos vivir en ese tipo de
ciudades Muchísimas gracias Carmen
cantuarias economista de medio ambiente
por haber venido hasta nuestros estudios
Gracias Aida y gracias a todos ustedes
por habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden también seguir por internet en rf
y mundo.com y France 24.com Hasta pronto
amigos
[Música]